this video was supported in part by our
friends at curiosity stream what F few
errs get 30 days completely free when
they click on the link in the
description below and use the promo code
what F there are billions of planets in
the universe that theoretically can
support life but so far we haven't
discovered any aliens out there maybe
the reason is we're just looking in the
wrong places
what if alien life isn't anything like
the life we know of what if it doesn't
need water or oxygen what if it can
withstand incredibly hot temperatures or
very acidic environments and what would
we need to search for to finally find it
this is what if and here's what would
happen if alien life was silicon-based
[Music]
there's one thing that your DNA a
diamond and a rubber duck have in common
they're all made of carbon carbon is one
of the most abundant elements in the
universe on earth it's also the primary
building block of all life carbon is so
special because it's atoms can make four
bonds with another element oxygen and
form long chains of atoms called
polymers but there is another element
that can do the same trick silicon not
only is silicon chemically similar to
carbon it also makes it on the list of
the most plentiful chemicals found in
the universe potentially silicon could
be a building block of organic alien
life and we might find that life in our
own solar system
a candidate for hosting a silicon-based
alien life is hiding among the moons of
Saturn Titan the biggest of these moons
has an atmosphere that's 95 percent
nitrogen and 5 percent methane it has no
oxygen and any water it has is frozen
solid
because Titan receives only 1% of the
amount of sunlight the earth does but
silicon-based life-forms wouldn't need
any water instead they could use liquid
methane as the galactic elixir for their
existence the lack of oxygen would also
be essential for such life to emerge
here's why when carbon unites with
oxygen or oxidizes as it does during a
fire it turns into a gas carbon dioxide
now when silicon oxidizes it becomes
silicon dioxide or silica which is a
solid and not a gas if Titan had oxygen
in its atmosphere silicon would
immediately turn into rock and no life
could possibly begin in that state but
Titan's atmosphere doesn't contain any
oxygen giving silicon-based life a
chance
what would this life look like how big
would the silicon species be would they
build their own civilization or invent
their own language well most likely if
there is silicon-based life out there it
would be in the form of microbes and not
animal sized organisms that you can see
with your own eyes
scientists generally agree that any
silicon-based life would need intense
heat to survive so most likely you'd
have to dig deep under the surface of
Titan to find it because of the extreme
cold on Titan surface a living being
would live somewhere close to titans
core where it's hot and hey there are
many planets out there some of them
might just have the right conditions for
non carbon-based life to thrive because
silicon doesn't get along with oxygen
the metabolic processes of a
silicon-based organism would have to be
entirely different from ours we don't
know if it's even possible just as we
don't know if anything strictly silicon
based would have a DNA but maybe we
shouldn't try applying our science to
alien life we've never encountered and
planets we haven't thoroughly explored
Earth's conditions don't really give
silicon any chance to form into a
life-form but if one day aliens came
down to visit us here on earth they
would probably change everything we know
about what living organisms could be
made of but that's a story for another
what if
thanks again to our good friends at
curiosity stream for lending their
support to this video if you didn't know
curiosity stream is a subscription
streaming service with thousands of
award-winning documentaries and
nonfiction titles for you to choose from
you can get unlimited access to
curiosity stream starting at just $2.99
a month or just $19.99 a year and what
if viewers get the first 30 days
completely free all you have to do is
sign up at curiosity stream comm slash
what if and use the promo code what if
during the signup process
[Music]